-Mon invitée est devenue verte
sans être écolo à ses débuts.
Elle se définit à la fois
comme utopiste et réaliste,
ce qui est plutôt rare en politique.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Eva Sas.
-Bonjour.
-Après le bac,
vous avez fait de la philo,
mais aussi l'ESSEC,
une grande école de commerce,
sauf que c'était pas pour devenir
une femme d'affaires.
Vous l'avez fait
"dans une perspective subversive,
un peu par entrisme".
Ca veut dire quoi ?
-J'ai constaté...
Mon père est d'une famille ouvrière
polonaise des Ardennes.
J'ai constaté que les ouvriers
étaient soumis,
et qu'il fallait
leur donner les clés
pour pouvoir gagner leur autonomie,
se défendre,
et c'est dans ce sens-là
que j'ai voulu connaître
le monde de l'entreprise,
connaître les clés,
les réflexions des actionnaires,
de façon à pouvoir les donner
à ceux qui en ont le plus besoin,
les salariés,
ceux qui, dans le rapport de force,
sont la partie faible.
-C'était une perspective politique,
pour changer le système,
mais ça ne passait pas
par l'engagement ?
-Comme beaucoup
de gens de cette génération,
et peut-être encore aujourd'hui,
j'étais méfiante
des partis politiques.
Pour moi,
ils ne changeaient pas le monde
et il fallait être dans l'action,
au plus près du monde du travail,
des salariés,
pour rééquilibrer
les rapports de force.
-Vous avez un côté très méthodique,
assez rigoureux...
Vous avez votre cahier.
-Absolument.
-Vous avez cette méthode,
cette rigueur,
ça vous a valu
d'être trésorière du parti,
d'être vice-présidente
de la commission des finances
à l'Assemblée,
et ça ne vous empêche pas
de vous revendiquer
de l'"utopie concrète",
ou encore...
de la "radicalité réaliste".
On peut faire cohabiter
ces notions
sans les dénaturer ?
-Oui, je pense que...
Pour être vraiment radical,
il faut être réaliste.
Il faut savoir
comment on va changer les choses.
Il faut être dans le concret,
dans le détail,
maîtriser les outils,
et c'est ce que j'essaye de faire.
J'ai plutôt un modèle
de cerveau d'expert,
j'aime décortiquer
les sujets au plus profond,
donc maîtriser les outils
et changer réellement les choses,
pas être dans la déclamation.
Pour moi,
ça ne s'oppose pas du tout.
Pour être radical,
il faut être réaliste.
-On retrouve ce côté
dans votre premier engagement,
le premier politique,
puisque vous vous êtes présentée
aux législatives en 1997,
pas sur l'écologie,
mais pour défendre
la semaine de 4 jours
aux côtés de Pierre Larrouturou.
Votre rêve,
c'était de travailler moins,
en quelque sorte.
C'est un peu le chômage
qui a déclenché
votre engagement ?
-C'est exactement ça.
Je sors de mes études
en 1993.
C'est un pic
dans le chômage des jeunes.
Je me rends compte
que toute une génération
est laissée de côté,
et je cherche des solutions
au chômage,
et je tombe
sur cette tribune,
dans Le Monde, je crois,
qui défend la semaine de 4 jours
et le partage du temps de travail.
"C'est la solution",
c'est pragmatique et impactant,
et je m'engage
dans un mouvement associatif,
à la base,
Un nouvel équilibre,
et on se présente aux élections,
en l'occurrence,
aux législatives et européennes,
mais c'est pour défendre nos idées,
des candidatures
de témoignage.
-Vous avez fait 0,8 %,
je crois.
-Oui, c'est ça.
0,86.
C'était pour le témoignage,
mais on se servait de cette tribune
que sont les législatives
pour parler du partage
du temps de travail.
C'était dans l'air du temps.
Peu après, c'était les 35 heures.
-De fil en aiguille,
à travers ce premier engagement,
vous avez découvert
et vous avez rejoint
Les Verts, en l'an 2000,
mais à l'époque,
ce qui a déclenché votre engagement,
c'est pas forcément
la dimension écologique.
-Vous dites "écologique".
Ce n'est pas forcément
la dimension environnementale.
Effectivement, Les Verts organisent
les états généraux de l'écologie,
et je rejoins ces états généraux,
et je découvre le programme
des Verts,
et je le dis souvent,
j'étais écolo sans le savoir,
car je croyais naïvement,
et beaucoup de gens
le croient encore, que Les Verts,
c'était uniquement l'environnement.
J'avais donné priorité, à l'époque,
plutôt au social.
Je découvre donc
que le programme des Verts,
c'est autre chose, c'est le partage
du temps de travail,
la société du temps libéré,
autonomie, responsabilité,
solidarité,
c'est un projet
de société global,
qui donne d'ailleurs cette autonomie
à l'individu,
qui fait en sorte
que chacun soit maître
de son destin.
Donc je me retrouve complètement,
en fait,
dans ces valeurs
et je découvre
que le programme social
et le programme démocratique
des Verts
sont étoffés.
C'est un projet de société global.
Je m'engage pleinement
jusqu'à aujourd'hui.
-Ensuite, vous avez eu
des fonctions importantes
et vous avez aussi été élue
aux municipales
et députée à deux reprises.
Vous avez longtemps refusé
de vous consacrer entièrement
à la politique. C'était important
d'avoir un métier,
pour vous. Pourquoi ?
-J'ai un métier,
et j'en suis fière.
Je suis expert auprès
des représentants du personnel,
auprès des CSE.
Et...
Pour moi, c'était d'abord
et avant tout le gage
de l'indépendance
en politique.
Ne pas dépendre
de la politique
pour gagner sa vie,
ça donne une liberté importante.
J'avais constaté
dans mes premiers engagements
que certains élus changeaient
de parti pour garder leur mandat.
J'ai trouvé ça triste.
Je voulais pas me retrouver
dans cette situation.
-Une compromission
sur les idées pour garder
son gagne-pain.
-Oui.
Quand on s'engage chez les verts,
c'est pas pour faire carrière
en politique.
C'est très aléatoire,
chez les écologistes.
Mieux vaut avoir un métier.
C'est une passion,
je l'aime énormément.
J'y reviendrai
si c'est nécessaire.
-Vous étiez dans un cabinet
d'expertise
qui accompagne les syndicats,
qui s'appelle Secafi.
C'est le slogan
de ce cabinet
qui a attiré
un peu votre regard,
"Réconcilier l'économique
et le social".
On dirait
un programme politique.
-C'est vrai.
-Vous avez fait
de la politique
par votre métier.
-C'est un métier engagé,
qui vise à donner
à la partie faible, aux salariés,
aux représentants du personnel,
les outils
pour se défendre,
et non prendre leur place.
C'est ce que j'aime aussi.
On leur donne
toutes les clés
pour qu'ils puissent se défendre
et être à armes égales
avec le même niveau
d'informations que les actionnaires
et les patrons.
-Il y a un fil rouge
dans votre engagement,
c'est votre combat pour le droit
des femmes. En 2013,
durant votre 1er mandat,
vous tombez enceinte,
et vous prenez conscience
que la situation
des femmes députées
n'était pas normale.
On va réécouter
votre prise de parole.
*-Il est temps que nos institutions
évoluent pour tenir compte
de la féminisation progressive
des Assemblées.
Or, rien n'est prévu
en cas de congé maternité
d'une élue.
Je vous demande un peu plus
solennellement ce soir
d'envoyer tout particulièrement
un message aux femmes pour leur dire
dans la vie politique
et cette Assemblée.
-Pour bien comprendre ça,
il faut savoir qu'une femme députée
qui est enceinte
peut partir en congés maternité,
mais elle sera pas
remplacée.
-Absolument.
Ca veut dire laisser
son siège vide.
C'est une responsabilité,
une culpabilité,
pour la femme qui part
en congés maternité,
car elle a l'impression
de ne pas remplir
son mandat.
Je proposais qu'elle puisse être
remplacée par son suppléant
ou sa suppléante
afin de...
de concilier, finalement,
ce qui est le quotidien,
le normal,
d'une vie de femme
et puis, ce mandat qu'on veut
remplir pleinement.
-Ca n'a pas été possible.
-Non.
La constitution a été écrite
par des hommes et pour des hommes,
donc le cas n'est même pas
envisagé.
-Pour changer ça,
il faudrait réviser la constitution.
-Oui, parce que c'est un article
de la constitution qui prévoit
où on peut être remplacé
par son suppléant.
Ils sont rares
et le congé maternité
n'en fait pas partie.
Nous devons mener ce combat.
Nous y arriverons.
A l'époque,
nous étions peu nombreuses à être
enceintes dans l'hémicycle.
Aujourd'hui, il y en a plus
grâce à la féminisation
et le rajeunissement aussi
de l'hémicycle.
Donc c'est devant nous.
Je pense qu'il y faudrait accélérer.
Cette intervention...
Ma fille a neuf ans.
Donc elle date
d'il y a neuf ans.
-On a vu récemment
plusieurs cas
de femmes députés enceintes,
certaines
avec des hautes fonctions
comme Aurore Bergé,
présidente du groupe Renaissance,
donc de la majorité
présidentielle.
Et les choses
n'ont pas changé !
-C'est un peu triste
de voir le temps qu'on met
pour des choses aussi évidentes.
Dans d'autres parlements
et au Parlement européen,
c'est tout à fait
possible et prévu.
Je trouve qu'on est en retard
et qu'il faut avancer
plus vite.
-Revenons sur le débat
que vous avez déclenché
à l'époque,
il y a eu pas mal
de réactions,
peu de femmes politiques
vous soutiennent
et d'autres ont
des réactions hostiles,
comme Michèle Alliot-Marie :
"Pendant qu'on y est,
pourquoi pas remplacer
"qui se casse la jambe ?"
-Il y a un vrai sujet.
Les maladies
ne sont pas prévues.
-Elle met le doigt dessus.
Ca vous a étonnée,
ces réactions
venant de femmes politiques ?
-Ca m'a pas complètement étonnée
parce que j'ai observé
que le féminisme n'est pas partagé
par toutes les femmes.
En particulier,
il est moins présent
chez les femmes de droite.
Il y a une façon, parfois,
chez certaines femmes,
de vouloir caché l'aspect féminin,
le fait d'être enceinte,
dans leur action politique.
Des femmes qui veulent revenir
tout de suite
dans l'hémicycle,
qui ne veulent pas
parler de leur maternité,
je trouve ça dommage.
Il faut assumer.
Il n'y a pas
à avoir honte,
à se sentir coupable de vivre
sa vie de femme
en même temps
que nous exerçons
notre mandat.
On me voit, là.
-Vous prenez la parole enceinte,
dans l'hémicycle.
Vous êtes allée
assez loin en restant présente
à l'Assemblée.
Vous étiez tiraillée
dans ce conflit de loyauté
entre vos électeurs
et votre futur bébé,
votre future famille ?
-C'est ça.
On nous a confié un mandat.
S'absenter longuement,
c'est évidemment une culpabilité
pour nous, élus.
Et je ne souhaite pas
que ça perdure
parce que nous n'avons pas
à subir cela.
-On va passer à notre quiz
à présent.
Je vous explique.
Je vais commencer une phrase
et vous devrez la compléter.
On y va ?
-Oui.
-Le plus dur,
quand on est une femme députée,
c'est...
-Le regard des hommes.
-Le regard des hommes ?
Ah, oui ?
-Il y a énormément...
-Sur votre façon de faire
de la politique ?
-Il y a toujours une forme de mépris
et de condescendance.
On l'observe dans l'hémicycle,
encore plus quand on est
une écologiste.
Il y a cet a priori
qu'on va être moins compétentes,
que l'on va être
plus "hystériques",
comme disent les hommes,
et qu'il faut toujours démontrer
alors que chez les hommes,
c'est finalement un acquis.
On ne demande pas
les mêmes preuves
de compétence aux hommes,
et c'est encore le cas
aujourd'hui.
-Pour un député,
la semaine de 4 jours,
c'est...
-C'est inexistant.
-Totalement utopiste ?
-Non, mais je pense qu'il y a
une réflexion à avoir
sur la charge de travail,
en tant que député.
Je pense que c'est assez inaudible
comme débat aujourd'hui.
Nous remplissons
notre tâche entièrement,
mais le partage
du temps de travail,
il vaut pour tous.
Le temps libéré,
la société du temps libéré
à laquelle nous aspirons,
ils doivent valoir aussi
pour les élus.
C'est une aspiration
de tout un chacun
qui vaut aussi pour nous.
-Etre subversif à l'Assemblée,
c'est...
-Là aussi, être à la commission
des finances et porter
des sujets radicaux...
Je l'ai choisie
aussi pour ça,
ça ne doit pas être
un débat entre experts.
Le changement de société
que nous souhaitons,
il passe aussi
par les débats
de finances publiques.
Une fois de plus,
bien maîtriser les outils,
pour les renverser et vraiment
avoir une société plus juste,
plus écologique,
plus environnementale et solidaire.
-Merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté l'invitation.
-Merci.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA